la existencia al mausoleo lima reza se
marcha del principal centro de
peregrinaje de irán
miles de familias como la el hoy
director del mausoleo llegaron de otras
partes del país para vivir cerca de la
tumba del octavo imán de los chiítas
lo que tenemos es gracias a las buenas
intenciones de nuestros padres
aquí la vida gira en torno al mausoleo
la economía es prospera gracias a
millones de peregrinos
y desde esta tribuna al principal
ayatolá de la ciudad
a la moda dictan las reglas sociales más
estrictas que en otras partes de irán
algunas de las principales figuras
religiosas han estado educadas en mashad
como el líder supremo de la revolución
más chata es la contraparte de teherán
que lidera la apertura social en irán en
esta ciudad impera en las ideas
conservadoras y recelosas de occidente
que se imponen en el escenario político
actual tres de los candidatos más
radicales a estas elecciones son
demasiado incluido el principal
opcionado el clérigo ebrahim raisi bombo
de raíz y es un hombre correcto que
busca ayudar a la gente
lejos del mausoleo hay otras visiones
del mundo
hay un grupo de gente y el gobierno
están hechos el uno para el otro
uno hace parte de un gran número de
artistas que se mover en espacios
alternativos
la vida de la mayoría de irán no es como
se venderán en países mucho más mucho
más con los pequeños cambios sociales
que se ven en espacios como estos cafés
han sido presionados por los jóvenes
pero hay todavía cientos de actividades
prohibidas como los conciertos la
entrada de dinero de otras actividades
como conciertos no son necesarios para
el gobierno local porque van a arriesgar
el sello religioso de la ciudad para
hacer
a poca gente feliz las normas no dejan
que artistas como me puedan vivir de lo
que ganan con la música así lo dejan de
intentarlo
[Música]